good morning Belize nation I'm Evan
Carmichael my one word is believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs are going to
solve all of the world's major problem I
started to believe life series to try to
step outside just the world of
entrepreneurship and learn from
different areas to try to help us become
better more well-rounded individuals who
can go out and have a big impact so in
today's episode we're going to learn how
you can learn a new language rule number
two is my personal favorite and I'd love
to know which one you guys like the back
and as always guys you're watching if
someone says something that really
resonates with you please leave it down
in the comments below a book quote
ceramics or other people can be inspired
and when you write it down to yourself
it's much more likely to stick for you
as well enjoy
[Music]
you
people do not know about me is people
see are learning from tourists but it
seems there's no way to learn English at
that time there's no teachers in our
city who can teach people to speak
English so I listen to the BBC and Voice
of America and there every evening 9
o'clock 8 o'clock to 9 o'clock I open my
video you know from the first Monday
Wednesday and Friday I listened to the
VOA the first book I heard about is the
adventure of Tom Sawyer and sometimes if
the signal is better I can listen to the
VP BC English world news so by listening
to them and there's English program for
these two radios so this struck me that
today there are so many kids in the
rulers the poor areas there is no
education if we can use not only rate
that that times the radio how about
using the internet your mobile phone and
pad and minutes it's much more fancier
modern and can keep the kids are much
better opportunity other you have a
favorite TV show you have a favourite
Netflix series and the desperate you can
probably find those equivalent in four
languages people we recommend my cooking
shows house hunters
The Voice the thing that you don't
really need to have a high level of
language please like smiles and express
like oh watch that a French house hunter
show you know more than house hunters
House Hunters International but you know
what I love even more
- calendar - no
International and fresh exactly this is
called CAPTCHA pasta movies old it's
weird I never watch TV but when I do if
usually cartoons and I watch you for
language versions of cartoons that I
already know so I'll watch an episode of
paint art on a nose in French because I
know what happened in English in that
episode it's not like you're completely
lost if you were to watch such a crime
scandalous seriously you're not going to
understand that in English the second
thing which I find really important to
learn a language is building the least
in these things because if you do not
have this page it will go anywhere I
tell you so babies believe that in
yourself in your ability that you can
learn it because if you don't believe
that from the start
you will not be successful and learning
if you're let's say starting off with
Spanish and you're saying oh my gosh
this is so difficult like you're halfway
you're already failing because you're
speaking no words already that you you
won't succeed and this is so true
because I see it when people start off
like where for example German German
okay if it's a difficult language but if
you are like oh my gosh it's so
difficult
I'm never going to learn it I have fears
so many people saying that even if
they're like really interested into
learning the language but I'm there
saying those words like out I don't know
why you even start because if you don't
have self believe that you can do it
even though it's difficult then where is
the point any like starting and there is
even studies that proof like the people
like polyglots for example and people
who have a hard time learning languages
the main difference between them is
basically that the people who have the
ability to learn many languages them
they're motivated and also they believe
they believe in themselves in their
abilities that they can do it actually
so if I go on and for example yeah like
my example what Portuguese I started
learning Portuguese by myself and I had
the belief and like no one that I was
like no I'm
when I learned that I'm never going to
be the one from the beginning I was like
okay I want to learn this I'm going to
learn it and I will and that's it and I
learned it as a globe but village
mysticism at the buy into you to hand
office I professional is to this
opposite a Gannicus cool drying on my
Sonya inner spanien most of this honest
game wouldn't miss Lawson hostage
Spanish to them as cannon escape
civility levan night Sophie the position
killing lemurs canceled much design
issue in our Wales which was the em er
Dao all are packing order only shorter
than my firm partner him from an ambush
this man okay try Sakura Ange our
official asana shop a fan you can offer
ideas from them anything
that's uber leaders it depends the
people that have goals of learning
Chinese because there's so many Mandarin
speakers out there anyway I always think
it's nice to combine it whether like
Matthew said whether it's a personal
goal whether you want to say maybe self
business in the Far East or even if it's
just because it's something that
interests you our parents have asked
sometimes I why why do you want to learn
breath on you know why do you learn
Japanese
I don't want to learn Japanese because
of a market I'd like to I'd like to
learn all of these languages but I don't
learn them because because of other
factors that other people are imposing
on me I like to learn a language because
it interests me because the culture
interests me because even silly things
like the way it's written I find it
fascinating
suiting screen or osorno motivo no la
razón por la que quieres aprender STD
oma yo wall simplemente de restaurante a
yachtie pass en espanol Aggie in Berlin
Oh n n Paris y esto Soto's si esto esto
jet Evo - yo creo que lo que tienes que
hacer es sagir seguir con este objetivo
un momento llego rasa decir lo que viene
para restaurant a ahora y pero para Mis
tapas en espanol many people say that
you should switch your mobile phone
settings to a foreign language to get
you straight but I actually don't
consider desig advice Ellie's not
Estados I mean everything
phone is pretty technical and I think
that you want to learn first how to talk
to people before you learn that [ __ ]
Amaya gentleman means display settings
hello it's me Trixie behind Oh [ __ ]
your entitlement logic these long
complicated words may discourage you so
my advice would be to do the same
language switch thing with a game you
play this doesn't work for any kind of
game of course if you switch for example
Skyrim through German you will learn
words like auto shops by Honda damn you
- tight which is the orcish great sort
of weariness and if is pretty awesome to
know that but when would you ever need
this in conversation hi JC we have
leather Ferguson he's not madam nice
mention walking shots fight another mood
each type how she stopped cute so if you
choose again make sure it plays in our
modern time or it at least uses our
modern language a point-and-click
adventure for example maybe one that you
like Monkey Island
you cannot play Monkey Island often
enough or for example this since to get
into contact with normal life happenings
there you encounter daily life
vocabulary in its natural context which
makes it easier to remember and also
easier to guess what it could mean just
make sure you don't end up speaking
Simlish so slowly come on Stella again
write everything down that you consider
helpful to easily learn a first set of
vocabulary that will come in handy for
normal conversations by sticky notes
write the German and English words for
everything in your flat or house on them
and pin each of them on to the item it
refers to of course not in fashion that
they will come off too easily or are
always in the way if you have a pet
that's not an appropriate item for this
method and also for example for the
mouth of your computer cups or Forks
this is just not possible so fine things
that this trick actually works it helps
you is seeing the word over and over
again and to learn it and memorize it
without much effort for the other
everyday items you can cross little
flash cards with pictures like these I
did and whenever you have some three
minutes just grab one and learn with it
talking about vocabulary don't just
write things down and try to remember
the words in your head so better and
funnier way is to amend little stories
for instance the cow means the COO in
if you go to remember well try that how
is the animal called in age and how and
what sound does a cow make can't move
exactly and now just put these two
together cool mind you know of course
this doesn't work for every single word
but just give your imagination a try
languages material vs. method I like
many people came to the conclusion that
I was terrible at languages I suffered
through Spanish for junior high first
year of high school and the sum total of
my knowledge was pretty much donde esta
el baño and I wouldn't even catch the
response sad state of affairs then I
transferred to a different school
sophomore year and I had a choice of
other languages most of my friends were
taking Japanese so I thought why not
punish myself I'll be Japanese six
months later I had the chance to go to
Japan and my teachers assured me this is
don't worry you'll have Japanese
language classes every day to help you
cope could be an amazing experience my
first overseas experience in fact so my
parents encouraged me to do it I left I
arrives in Tokyo Mazen couldn't believe
I was on the other side of the world met
my host family things went quite well I
think all All Things Considered my first
evening before my first day of school
I said to my mother very politely please
wake me up at 8 a.m.
so excuse me of course to go outside but
I didn't say of course the once I said
huh kids meal customers outside pretty
close but I said please rape me at 8
a.m.
you've never seen a more confused
Japanese woman
and I walked into school and a teacher
came up to me and handed me a piece of
paper and I couldn't read any of it
hieroglyphics it would it could have
been because it was kanji so Chinese
characters adapted into the Japanese
language asked him what this said and he
goes ah ok ok it why do they study a
cough give us a cold uncle being
traditional Japanese and so on and it
came to me in waves there had been
something lost in translation
the Japanese classes were not Japanese
instruction classes per se they were the
normal high school curriculum for
Japanese students the other 4999
students in the school who were Japanese
besides the American and that's that's
pretty much my response and that set me
on this panic driven search for the
perfect language method I tried
everything on its Kinokuniya I tried
every possible book every possible CD
nothing worked until I found this this
is the joy of kanji John this is a
tablet rather or a poster of the 1945
common use characters is determined by
the Ministry of Education in 1981 many
of the publication's in Japan limit
themselves to these characters to
facilitate literacy some are required to
and this became my holy grail my rosetta
stone and as soon as I focused on this
material I took off and I ended up being
able to read Asahi Shinbun a fighting
newspaper about six months later so
total of eleven months later and went
from Japanese one to Japanese six end up
doing translation work at age 16 when I
returned to the US and have continued to
apply this material over method approach
to close to a dozen languages now
someone who was terrible languages and
at any given time speak read and write
five or six and this brings us to the
point which is it's often times what you
do not how you do it that is the
determining factor this is the
difference between being expected doing
the right things and being sufficient
doing things well whether or not they're
important and you can also do this with
grammar I came up with the six sentences
after much experimentation having a
native speaker allow you to deconstruct
their grammar by translating these
sentences into past present future we'll
show you
subject-object-verb placement in direct
direct objects gender and so forth from
that point you can then if you want to
acquire multiple languages alternate
them so there's no interference so we
can talk about that if anyone's
interested and now I love languages
thank you guys so much for watching I'd
love to know what did you think of this
video what was the biggest takeaway that
you're going to immediately apply
somehow in your life or maybe your
business let me know leave it down the
comments below really curious to find
out I also want to give a quick shout
out to bull Hawkins from four-minute
masters com both thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and doing that fun interview
together I really appreciate this
apartment and I'm hoping that you are
enjoying the read so thank you guys so
much for watching I hope you have an
amazing day I believe in you hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
see I always thought I had the thing
that was a little bit of food craziness
that I did and then I realized how
useful it was I always did what I like
to call shallower conversations and
shower conversations are exactly what
they sound like when I was learning a
new language
I was stay in the shower for a few
minutes and I remember having all these
discussions I remember when I was
learning Chinese and I would hable and
like try to get to UN more on to get
that done wonderful dumpling and getting
the discount or I would go to Rome I now
threw directions to the best Piazza it
was amazing and the beautiful thing
about a shower conversation is that it
allows you to find wherever you have a
gap in your knowledge because you're
having a conversation on both ends for
example it's easy to ask for directions
how about receiving them or even better
giving directions
well the shower conversation forces you
to have both sides of the conversation
and you don't need to have them in the
shower the wonderful thing about them is
was that you can have them anywhere so
you can have them the shower in your
apartment walking down the streets in
the subway and seriously if you're in
the subway speaking to yourself in a
foreign language in New York you'll fit
right and you're fine and it's great
because it doesn't you don't depend on
anything or anyone get your practice and
I did this for years and later on I
found out that professional athletes do
too Michael Phelps is known to visualize
every single one of his races several
times over before jumping in the water
works great for him and it works great
for me too so it would work for you as
well now when it comes to learning your
language perhaps the most crucial
element is time and by time I don't mean
years upon years of endless learning as
some people still like to think how long
does it take to learn a language how
about if I were to tell you that 30
minutes per day are a great and
effective start now 30 minutes is a
minutes that we all have
the ten in the morning ten in the
afternoon ten in the evening or thirty
minutes in simply one goal on the way to
work to university to school out an
evening meeting friends whilst on the
train our boss we all have these minutes
that we can commit to learn furthermore
by learning for smaller periods and
regular intervals we won't feel so
overwhelmed by the language and even
better learning for regular periods
means that it's more effective because
chances are that if you're learning for
once a week or once a fortnight by the
time you next come to learn you'll
already have forgotten what you
initially learnt the goal therefore is
to fit language learning into our daily
routines and not the other way around
and by doing this there's no reason why
after simply one month you can't get by
in your new language a third action
start mixing you probably have never
thought of this but if you've got ten
verbs 10 nouns and 10 adjectives you
could say 1000 different things right
language is a creative process what a
babies do okay me but now okay that's
how they communicate
so start mixing get creative have fun
with it doesn't have to be perfect just
has to work and you when you're doing
this you focus on the core what does
that mean well with every language of
high-frequency content in English 1000
words covers 85% of anything you're ever
going to say in daily communication 3000
words gives you 98% of anything you're
going to say in daily conversation
you've got 3,000 words you're speaking
the language the rest is icing on the
cake and when you're just beginning with
a new language start with your toolbox
week number one in your new language you
say things like how do you say that I
don't understand repeat that place what
does that mean all in your target
language you're using it as a tool
making it useful to you it's relevant to
learn other things about the language by
week
you should be saying things like me this
you that give you no hot simple pronouns
simple nouns simple verbs simple
adjectives communicating like a baby and
by the third or fourth week you're
getting into what they call glue words
although but therefore these are logical
transformers that tie bits of a language
together allowing you to make more
complex meaning at that point you're
talking